the fierce hurricane is churning between
Cuba and the Bahamas right now
Irma is expected to turn north toward
Florida tomorrow more than a million
people have been told to leave the
massive storm is about the size of
France right now Jeff Glor is leading
our coverage from Miami Jeff our
residents heeding the warnings many of
them are yes bianna good to see you
storm surges are a huge concern with
this hurricane hurricane Irma FEMA
estimates about two and a half million
Florida homes are in flood hazard zones
many of those homes are in this densely
populated area we're in Miami Dade
County Broward County to our north where
more than four and a half million people
live overall that includes the cities of
Miami and Fort Lauderdale and one of the
best ways to understand the threat to
low-lying areas is to see them from
above veteran helicopter pilot Paul
Barth
took us on a tour of the Miami coastline
that's under the threat of dangerous
storm surge this is the most low life of
all people area of biamby right here
birth witness the devastation firsthand
when a cat5 hurricane struck here in
1992 this is a low area here not very
much but two or three feet above sea
level so if we have a strong storm surge
there's not much to protect it to the
coastline moving in on this side this
bout of Key Biscayne here though it's
wide open to the Atlantic Ocean
just north of Miami the Broward County
Emergency Operations Center is already
running full tilt
with members from every County
Department on hand this area is humming
it is because this is where the calls
are coming in and they're arranging for
services Broward County Mayor Barbara
Sharif says storm surge flooding is her
biggest worry right now along with
neighbors complying with evacuation
orders so our concern is that we're
gonna have to try to rescue people what
we may have got some fatalities and so
right now this preparation process is to
minimize that mayor Sharif says that
Broward County is ready for whatever
Irma does bring their way she warns
people who decide to ride out the storm
that once winds reach a sustained level
of 45 miles an hour the county cannot
send emergency personnel in for them we
will likely get winds that are more than
three times that amount let's go back to
Nora now in New York or important point
that's why those evacuation orders are
so important Jeff thank you for your
reporting